foreign
it's about getting rid of 50 of your
clothes I think that this is interesting
because quite often people struggle with
clothes clutter even though it's
probably the easiest area to start it's
either the junk drawers or your closet
although I would just say this your
closet is generally a junk drawer for
your unworn clothes there's a question I
have for you is what would happen
if you got rid of 50 of your clothes I
would have five T-shirts instead of ten
not you damn it oh my bad
but I think
what would happen is they would actually
enjoy their clothes more because they're
not going to get rid of the 50 of the
clothes that they like the most that
they wear the most that they enjoy the
most they go into the claws and they say
this 50 of the clothes either I wear
infrequently or I don't wear it at all I
still have things from three years ago
that have tags on it and it's a problem
not because well it's not a problem
they're just sitting there in your
closet it's sitting there in your mind
you're constantly neurosing about those
things and by the way they're getting in
the way of the clothes you do wear
you're you have the clothes you wear
piled underneath the clothes you don't
wear in your drawers or in your bins or
on hangers and so it just makes in fact
you sent me this Tick Tock the other day
Ryan so good it was maybe Jordan can
superimpose it in the video after the
fact since we don't have access to it
right now but basically it is this
person who opens up the closet and
there's a hoodie hanging explain the
hoodie too it's like a bright orange you
know bright neon colored hoodie and the
the joke was like there was someone in
the hoodie and all you could see was
their head poking out and like
legitimately they were in the hoodie and
they were like hi there it's been a
while
love me it's me love me pick me love me
pick me and then the very last second of
the video he just scoots it over and
picks a different hoodie yeah he's like
he's like get out of here
[Laughter]
but I wanted to bring this up this
question because I asked myself this
question recently I just donated half of
my jackets now oh my that's huge for you
man long time listeners will know that
my wife calls me a jacket yeah
dirty little jacket I'm rather
promiscuous when it comes to Jackson I
barely own anything do you ever wear two
at once
oh it just didn't feel right right
um but here's what I'll say about those
jackets so I used to think I had six
jackets which felt like too many I
actually had eight jackets and I said
what would happen if I got rid of half
of these well mathematically we just
mean I have four jackets left and the
question was do I need four jackets
because I don't really own much I don't
have two pairs of pants and I only have
two pairs of pants because one of them
ripped and I had to get it repaired and
I need to buy another pair of pants to
wear while I was getting the other pants
replaced yeah I have I don't know maybe
a dozen or so shirts t-shirts long
sleeves short sleeve Etc and of course I
have underwear socks and shoes but I
just don't own a whole lot of clothes
I'm totally fine with it I found shirts
that work well for me
and yet I always had the layer of
accessory with a jacket right yeah yeah
and the the problem was I wore all eight
of those jackets relatively regularly
but we have this rule called the
duplicates rule just because I wear
something from time to time is not a
good enough reason for me to keep it
because it was taking up a lot of space
for me not just in my closet but also I
was thinking about it do I really need
all of these jackets or am I really
getting the value from it could I get
just as much value from having fewer or
might I even get more value from having
fewer and so now I own four jackets and
they all have a different function one's
an actual coat so when it gets cold
especially I live in Ojai so it'll get
in the low 30s throughout the winter so
I have an actual coat I have a light
jacket that I can wear out that isn't as
heavy I have a dress up sort of jacket
we wore it to an event we just went to
recently with Dave Ramsey I wore that
jacket and it looked like I was wearing
some something that was a little more
sleek and not even just a regular plain
black jacket I want my tuxedo t-shirt
sorry about another one the final one I
have is a rain jacket which I actually
bought last year because it was raining
so much throughout the winter I realized
I needed a rain jacket and so yes I had
eight jackets now I have four could I
get by with fewer yes I could live with
zero jackets but minimalism is not about
living with zero living with nothing or
going without it's about understanding
what is appropriate for me and right now
I've identified what's appropriate for
me yeah you could survive but you would
not Thrive and minimalism is not about
survival only it's really about that
that's right it's about the Rival that's
right Revival I'm trying to think who
here has who like yeah who who has your
same size shoulders it definitely isn't
me Jordan I've donated jackets to him
before in the past I realized I wasn't a
leather jacket guy I wish I was but
Jordan is I mean he is we hired him only
because he's so cool that bastard and he
doesn't know how to do video stuff it's
actually Sean's doing the video things
right now we just needed someone to sit
there and look cool with a leather
jacket yeah yeah he fulfills that
criteria you can you can totally pull
denim off though which is kind of sweet
I donated my denim jacket no I know man
you don't even know me anymore oh my God
I can't even call you James Dean anymore
a a brief philosophy of clothes in the
closet everything in your closet is
either a commitment to your future or
it's some aspect of your past that
you're not willing to let go you in
theory could go down each item in your
closet and you can ask yourself
do I intend to wear this or you can ask
yourself hey is this something that I no
longer intend to wear but it was just
valuable for me and so those two
questions would be when and why if I
intend to wear it when do I intend to
wear it if I no longer intend to wear it
then why do I still have it around and
if you ask those questions when and why
about everything in your closet and you
can't come up with an answer to it then
it might be time to Let It Go not
because you have to but because you
don't want to compromise your life by
living in a space between a future that
you're not willing to commit to and a
past that no longer serves you did you
enjoy this Standalone patreon highlight
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free